bonjour guillaume la scuderia ce jour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes historien militaire
enseignement à la sorbonne je le disais
sergueï lavrov a repris presque mot à
mot le discours de vladimir poutine sur
cet élargissement notamment de l'otan à
l'est c'est ça le gros problème c'est en
fait tout à fait le coeur du problème
c'est à dire que c'est une
mécompréhension là encore radical de ce
qu'est l'otan 2 comment fonctionne
l'otan et le coeur du sujet et et c'est
bien le propos de lavrov c'est de dire
voilà il y a eu des promesses des
promesses de nonne élargissement on
revient sur la encore 30 ans de de
manipulation finalement de la formation
d'un discours qui en fait est totalement
faux c'est vrai qu'il n'ya jamais eu de
promesse faite il ya j'ai eu de mort
promesse formalisé donné l'argent sale
coeur du débat également qu est ce qui a
été promis aux pas promis et il y à 30
ans à la chute de l'urss on revient se
fait sur ce que james baker à l'époque
le secrétaire d'état à la défense avait
dit à gorbatchev ce qui est resté en
fait un petit peu dans la mentalité et
soviétiques et russes à savoir que les
pays qui sortirait du bloc de l'est ou
du pacte de varsovie n'intégrerait pas
l'otan sauf que james baker d'état le
poids de faire ce genre de promesse que
rien n'a été écrit et que même tous les
documents dits déclassifiés qui serait
en secret et qui aurait dit que cette
promesse a été faite rien n'a été
formalisé puis surtout c'est oublier une
chose c'est que pour l'otan il a tout le
temps été marquée que les pays était
souverain de choisir leur agrément de
défense les pays qui ont rejoint l'otan
depuis la chute du mur depuis les années
1990 et 2000 l'ont fait comme des états
souverains elles n'ont pas été forcée ni
d'un côté par washington et surtout
elles ont effectivement fait contre la
menace venue moscou et on voit quel
point perdu par dax allemand elles ont
eu raison la présidente de la georgie le
disait il ya quelques jours sur notre
antenne pour elle et bien vladimir
poutine va réussir là où les européens
ont finalement échoué c'est-à-dire
constituer une défense européenne
finalement contre lui alors
effectivement
on pourrait presque dire de manière
ironique que en l'espace d'une semaine
vladimir poutine a réussi à faire mieux
avancer la défense européenne que 50 ans
d'essais de tentatives de discours et de
et de sommer et ce virage historique de
l'allemagne notamment oui tout à fait on
peut observer à quel point effectivement
les annonces faites par olaf scholz on
renvoyait finalement presque et et
remise manière caduque 30 ans de hausse
politique d'ouverture
vers la russie d'une sorte de de
balancier géopolitique un petit peu un
petit peu difficile à tenir aujourd'hui
et effectivement les annonces que
l'allemagne porte à la fois son budget
de défense à plus de 2% de son pib avec
des investissements immédiats de l'ordre
de 50 milliards supplémentaires c'est
effectivement quelque chose de tout à
fait original une défense européenne au
détriment de l'otan non non il faut bien
voir qu'en fait les deux les deux vont
sans doute se structurellement se
superposer et sa compagne et il faut
bien comprendre qu'on ne peut pas être
crédible à l'union européenne si on
n'est pas crédible à l'otan et créer un
pilier de défense européen au sein de
l'otan ça paraît normal quand vous voyez
que 23 des 30 pays sont membres à la
fois des deux organisations et l'ukraine
en tout cas le président ukrainien
disait il ya deux semaines qu'il rêvait
de rejoindre l'otan n'est plus sur un
statut neutre aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de neutralité véritablement là dont il
est question puisque on est quand même
en train de parler d'un pays qui est en
guerre déjà l'une par donc que la
neutralité en période de guerre ce
toujours un petit peu compliqué la
deuxième chose c'est que il y avait en
fait au sommet de bucarest en 2008 une
promesse qui a été faite et à la géorgie
et à l'ukraine qu'ils auraient la
possibilité d'intégrer l'otan mais il
n'y a pas de date qui était donné et
surtout tout c'est tous ces éléments là
ont été rebattues très largement à
partir de 2014 ils le sont encore plus
aujourd'hui
il est comme très difficile de dire
aujourd'hui à l'ukraine vous allez être
membre de l'otan d'autant plus que la
plupart des pays européens là-dessus
considère effectivement que ce serait
non seulement un chiffon rouge agité
devant poutine et lui permettre
finalement d'avoir de justifier
finalement un conte a posteriori sans de
son discours je ne crois pas que ce soit
à l'ordre du jour éloigne ou non un tout
petit peu de l'otan sur la stratégie
militaire de vladimir poutine ainsi que
l'ukraine ses 43 millions d'habitants
pour l'instant il ya deux cent mille
soldats est ce que le risque militaire
n'était-il pas trop grand aujourd'hui
pour vladimir poutine est ce que il
n'est pas vouée à l'échec 7 c est ce que
cette offensive n'est pas vouée à
l'échec c'est pas toujours c'est
toujours très difficile de dire au bout
d'une semaine que des troupes se sont
enlisées je crois qu'il faut revenir sur
des éléments qui sont bizarrement
factuel une armée blindée mécanisée l
avance quand elle est en situation de
conquête et d'offensive de entre 15 et
20 ou 25 km par jour donc vous prenez
par exemple les unités qui sont sortis
ont débouché de la crimée elles ont
réalisé en l'espace d'une semaine
quasiment 200 à 230 km donc elles ne
sont pas totalement bloqué c'est assez
pour le suivi d'un lien c'est bruxelles
qui effectivement sont en train de
contourner et d'installer peut-être un
siège autour de kiev ont probablement eu
plus de difficultés mais ça tient en
fait à la logistique russe la logistique
russe paraît effectivement un petit peu
plus chaotique un petit peu plus
désordonnée on annonce effectivement des
problèmes de ravitaillement mais ça
tient aussi peut-être à la structure de
l'armée russe elle s'est largement
réorganisé à partir de 2008 j'avais d'un
effort de 2 transformations de brigade
isation
d'allègement des unités russes sans leur
en donnait forcément les moyens
logistiques et on observe que la
affectivement c'est un petit peu plus
chaotique ça ne veut pas dire pour
autant que
leurs efforts et leur offensive soit
totalement définitivement arrêté ils
sont peut-être simplement en train de se
réorganiser de se ravitailler de se
remettre en condition et à partir du
moment où ils auront les les éléments
qui leur permettront de re passer à
l'assaut je crois qu'on observera ce
moment une toux me reprend et on va
suivre bien sûr